to accepting what is right,
rejecting what is false. These
are things that many of us know
consciously that we are
supposed to do, right? As
Muslims, we are supposed to
accept accept truth. We are
supposed to reject falsehood
and so forth but there are
millennia. There are
hindrances. Things that get in
the way of us accepting the
truth and rejecting falsehood.
What I mean by accepting the
truth and rejecting falsehood
is not just accepting it and
saying, yes, I believe that.
When you accept something that
is the truth, it affects your
actions. It affects your
speech. So, if you accept a
verse from the Quran, it
changes you and it changes your
actions and it changes your
heart and it changes your
outlook and it changes the way
that you see the world and it
changes the way that you speak
and it changes the way that you
deal with others and it may
change your sleep pattern and
it may change your diet and it
may change all kinds of things,
alright? And so, acceptance is
not just lip service, just I
accept that. Yes This is true
and this is false. That's not
that's not that's very
superficial acceptance.
Acceptance of the truth is when
it is received by the heart and
finds a place there to reside.
Where a person will be affected
by these things that they have
accepted. Likewise, rejection
of falsehood is not to just
say, oh I reject this. I don't
agree with this, etcetera but
it will affect your actions.
So, let's give an example on
that. Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
and he said, he mentions and
this chapter we've been in for
a long time, right? We're
about, we're about close to the
end but this chapter is one of
the most important chapters in
all of Zed al Maat. In fact, it
was it's to be so important
that some scholars have taken
this chapter alone and written
entire books on explaining and
expounding upon the meanings of
this chapter. Because of its
importance and because of the
depth of the things that
lawless if Ibn al Kaim Rahim
Allah wish to expound upon
these meanings. more than he
did in the original text. It
would have been the the book
would have ballooned up much
much larger than it already is
and actually, we could say,
subjectively that his other
book, Madera Giuselikin, Madara
Giuselikin, the stations and
the levels of those who are on
their way to Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala is kind of an
explanation of this chapter,
really. Yeah. Whole book and
it's a very long book. It's a
it's about 1500 pages long and
it's essentially an explanation
of but
these things
that he list here
and brevit with brevity in he
has expounded upon in other
places and other works of his
such as Madera Giuselikin which
was one of his most most
received books and one of his
most expansive books with
regards to the heart and its
connection to Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala and the journey of
person takes throughout his
life on his way to meeting
Allah. Subhanahu wa ta'ala.
That's what book is actually
about. This book is about the
prophet and following in that
line what is part of his
sunnah? What is part of his
way? What is what is what is
the what are the causes for us
to accept his sunnah? and
accept what we learn from this
book. Well, these things that
he lists. There are other
things as well but the topic of
this book just does not allow
too much too much detail on
these issues. So, we have spent
a lot of time in this chapter
which we are bringing the words
of from his other works into
our explanation of this
chapter. Even though this
chapter, we could have breached
through it and and and 15
minutes and kept going.
However, it's a very very
important chapter which is why
I had chose to take the route
of spending a lot of time in
this chapter because it deals
with the heart. It deals with
the heart being opened. If the
heart's not open, the rest of
the book is not going to be of
use and so,
he is listing these things that
act as a cause for the heart to
be open, open to the prophet
and as I mentioned, when a
person accepts something as
truth, it has to be accepted to
the point that it affects his
or her. That it affects his or
her actions, right? And speech
and outlook and whatever it is
and likewise when a person
rejects falsehood, it it it has
to purge itself from a person's
actions and speech and demeanor
and thought. This is what truly
rejecting and accepting means.
It's not merely to just, you
know, say, yes, I believe the
Quran is true and I read it and
you know, I breached through it
and at the end of reading the
Quran, I'm the same guy was the
no matter how many times you
read the Quran. Sometimes,
people read the Quran once a
month. Some people read the
Quran once every three weeks.
Some people read the Quran once
every two weeks. Some people
read the Quran once every week,
once every three days. No
matter how many times you read
the Quran, if you are the same
person at the end that you were
at the beginning, you have not
read the Quran. You may have
worded it. You may have mouthed
its words but you did not read
the Quran. Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala said
He said in those whom we have
given the book to, meaning of
the companions of the prophet
and those righteous that came
before, they recite and follow
its recitation the way that it
should be followed. Those are
the ones who have
have
truly believed in the
Quran. So, we Understand from
this that faith, when we say
faith, what is faith? I say
belief. Belief is not an
adequate word, okay? That's not
enough.
They have the scholars of they
have clearly identified and
defined the meaning of in the
Quran and in the Sunnah what is
Al Iman? Al Iman in the
language christically, language
wise. It is not only just a
belief but a belief that is so
strong and so deeply accepted
and embedded in a person's
heart. That it that it demands
action and it demands ad
herence. So, if a person
believes in something, it will
demand ad herence. If they
merely know it, but they do not
but it they do not ad here to
what they know. This is not
what is meant by belief in the
Quran and Sunnah, right? And
so, as the scholars have also
mentioned, belief, what is
belief? Belief is basically
five things. Number one, it is
acceptance and belief in the
heart and it manifests itself
and it is a speech with the
tongue and it is also something
that articulates itself in
actions and it increases with
the obedience of Allah and
decreases with the disobedience
of Allah. Subhanahu wa ta'ala.
That is the meaning of imam.
So, what is a man? Iman? It is
belief in the heart. And also
actions of the heart. It
speech. It is action, and it
increases with obedience to
Allah and it decreases with the
disobedience of Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala. So, it fluctuates
based on a person's, a person's
actions and speech, and the
strength of their belief. An
example of this, when we say a
person believes something but
they did not ad here to it that
it is not belief. A very good
example. There are many
examples in the Quran but
there's one that comes to mind
in
Allah says,
and
[Silence]
of these verses of the Quran of
the Sunnah. They disbelieve in
them and they make fun of them
and they make light of them.
Allah says, so do not sit in
their company as they do that.
unless they, unless they speak
about another topic, right? So,
in Medina, there were Muslims
and non Muslims and households
were shared by both Muslims and
non Muslims, right? So, some of
the people in the household may
be Muslim and others may be non
Muslims. They may be Jewish.
They may be idolaters, they may
be unMuslims, whatever it is
and so, the that was in every
home, however, was the prophet
and the Quran that he came
with. This is something that
was spoken about and discussed
at length by everybody because
it was so compelling and so, it
entered every home. However, in
these homes, sometimes the non
Muslims in these homes would
begin to make lights or even
mock these verses of the Quran
that were revealed and disbeli
in them and speak about their
disbelief and express their
disbelief in them and so forth.
So, there would be Muslims in
the home as well. Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala ordered the
Muslims do not sit in these
gatherings. If this is what is
happening, if if if the Quran
and the Sunnah are being
rejected out outwardly and they
are being made a mockery of,
then, you are not to sit in
these gatherings. Until day,
speak about another topic. You
know you have your parents or
whoever it is in the home
that's not Muslim. They speak
about other topics that are
neutral. That's fine. You can
sit with them and you can speak
with them about that. But if
the topic of Allah and his
messenger come up and they
begin to make a mockery of it
or make light of it or
etcetera. Then you are too.
Remove yourself from that
gathering. And you are not to
sit in a gathering that.
What does Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala then say right after? He
says if you continue to sit in
that gathering, even if you're
not speaking, you're not to,
you're not, you're not saying
yes, I agree or no you're just
you're just there, right?
You're just present in that
gathering. He says, if you are
doing that, then you are the
same as them. You are equal to
them. But do we understand from
this? We understand from this
that yes, I believe in Allah in
the last day but if I sit in
such a gathering and it doesn't
affect me to the point where I
have the inclination to remove
myself or speak out, then, this
is not really belief. This is
just a very superficial belief.
True belief, expresses itself
on a person's tongue and a
person's action if it doesn't,
if it doesn't demand ad
herence, then it's not belief.
It hasn't reached a deep enough
part in your heart for you to
have truly believed in it,
right? And so, When we say the
the the causes for the heart to
be open, understand that Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala he has
referred to himself in the
Quran and he has said
have you planted it or are we
the ones who plant? So Allah is
referred to himself in that way
that he plants seeds that he
sows seeds and to sow seeds, to
plant a seed in the ground, you
have to disturb the earth. You
have to open it up. It's a
violent process, right? And
that's what learning is. You
come to learn something,
something that you thought is
the way or you're comfortable,
right? But the Quran and the
Sunnah, they have in order for
them to be planted properly.
There has to be pickaxe or
there has to be a shovel that's
taken and then the earth has to
be disturbed and broken apart
in order to reach a place where
that seed can find it, can find
its its bed so that it will
grow and be nourished and that
process is uncomfortable,
right? It's uncomfortable. The
Earth is nice and flat and
leave it it is. Yeah, if
we leave it it is, we
won't get any fruits. So, in
order to get those fruits, we
have to first destroy and then
we have to repair. right? And
so,
is speaking about the things
that will open up the earth in
order for those seeds to be
sown in order for those seeds
to be planted. What are the
things that a person can do and
what are the things that Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala does in
order to disturb that earth and
open it up and open up a caveat
in it. Deep enough in order
that
seed may be sown That a seed
may be embedded into that earth
so that we can have some
results, right and so this is
what this chapter is about.
That's why it's such an
important chapter of and I
encourage everybody to not only
be suffice with what it is we
say here but also go online,
look up you know, Zad Al Maad
for Ibn Al Kaim in Arabic, in
English. You don't have to buy
the book. Look it up. Go to
this chapter. Read what he
says. Right? Research it. This
is this is this is how
knowledge is sought. This is
how knowledge is is is
implemented The seventh thing
he, seventh thing that he
mentions is of the things that
open the heart is a
says, bravery. bravery. Bravery
is one of the keys to opening
the heart. Is a person who is
brave and is courageous and has
valor. This person, their heart
is open. What does that mean?
How could bravery have
something to do with that? It
has a big, it has a big role to
play. That is when a perfect
person is brave. What is
bravery? Doesn't mean that
you're not scared. Everybody
get scared. Everybody gets
nervous. Everybody gets
anxiety, right? The brave, the
courageous, they are able to
push away that feeling and do
what needs to be done. That's
the ultimate really of, that's
the ultimate of what the truth
is. Isn't it? Is that you
receive the truth? It's
uncomfortable. The ground is
being dug. It's being
disturbed. You're uncomfortable
with what is being said.
However, you have the bravery
and the courage to accept it in
spite of whatever the
consequences or whatever the
results may be. When I say
bravery and courage, most of
us, what comes to our mind is
bravery and violence and that's
not what I'm speaking about.
That is an aspect of bravery,
an aspect of bravery is in
violence, in times of violence,
in times of war, in times of
physical violence where there's
physical harm that could be put
on a person right? A person
could be afflicted with.
that's a type of bravery that
you put yourself in harm's way
because you know that this
thing needs to be done or this
thing cannot happen, right?
However, the bravery is much
more broad than that. There's a
lot of types of bravery bravery
An example of bravery is
accepting the message and
following the what's good in a
bad world. Everybody will point
fingers at you and say, what
are you doing, man? This is
this is ridiculous. This is
this. This is that. Look at the
rest of the world. It's a very
dark world and you're trying to
keep a light lit in it, right?
It's a dark world. It's a bad
world and you're trying to be
good. That's a type of bravery.
You're trying to be good in a
bad world. people around you or
snakes in the grass. They lie.
They have many faces. Not just
two faces. The prophet said
in the
he said in the worst of people
are
[Silence]
Unfortunately, we live in a
world where it's not just
[Silence]
what he has told us through his
revelations and his prophets.
That's what right and wrong is
and so, If the whole world is
doing something wrong or if the
majority or if you see
everybody and and it looks like
they're getting ahead, you
know, they're getting ahead and
they're they're doing these
things and it's working out for
them and here I am. I'm not
doing it. That's a type of
bravery. You're being
courageous. You're facing a
cold world because you're
holding on to a book and a
hope. That's all we have
really, right? We have a book
and we have a promise from
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. We
have a hope that All will
fulfill that promise Not that
Allah won't fulfill his promise
but that we meet the criteria
for him to fulfill his promise.
That's what we hope for. Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala will always
fulfill his promise. But he
also says fulfill my fulfill my
fulfill your obligations and I
will fulfill mine. Fulfill your
your half of the agreement and
I will fulfill mine. So we hope
that Allah will fulfill his
promise with us. Meaning that
we hope that we will make
ourselves eligible for his
promise of forgiveness and
salvation before we leave this
earth and this world. That's
what's meant, right? And so,
the issue here, the issue here
is,
braver
y. Not just talking about
being a tough guy. Not just
talking about in the face of
violence. That that's something
that yes, it takes bravery to
do that but it's really not
that difficult, right? Because
when when violence is
occurring, sometimes you are
sucked into it and you have no
other choice but to engage in
that in in that violence. And
that is a type of bravery. But
there's other bravery it's much
more, much much more subtle
what we mentioned. Trying
to uphold the words of Allah
even though a lot of people or
many people or most people or
all the people or whatever it
is, do not uphold the word of
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
Being honest while the while
while the majority are
dishonest. Being being doing
the right thing when the
majority not only are not doing
the right thing but scorn you
and look down at you and point
fingers at you for doing the
right thing. The prophet said
Islam
Muslim he said Islam began
strange and it would return to
being strange just as it began.
You know, this narration, just
as it began, it will return to
being strange. How, what what
does that mean? It was strange
when it began. Meaning, when
the prophet arrived as a
prophet and he told people, do
not worship idols. true
brotherhood is found in Allah
True love is for the sake of
Allah. be honest, keep good
ties with your kin. Stand up
for what is right. defend
the weak. Defend the the give
of what you have. Don't be
stingy. Etcetera. Etcetera. All
of these things that he
mentions. Pray and These were
very strange ideas People
didn't take them very well.
Most of them didn't what
he was saying. Because people
found their pride in their
lineage. I'm from the tribe of
so and so. I am I am of this
race. Therefore, I am superior.
So, the prophet came and did
away with that. Said, no,
you're not superior.
Superiority comes not in the
color of your skin or your
lineage, superiority comes in.
The veracity of your actions,
your legacy, and your station
and with Allah. That's what
real honor is. People didn't
that, right? So, it was
strange. It was strange to them
and not only was it strange but
people pointed fingers at them
and they made jokes about them
and they mocked them. The the
early companions. Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala said
The life of this world has been
made beautiful in the eyes of
those who disbelieve and they
make a mockery of the
believers. They make jokes
about them. They point at them.
They they they they you know
mock them and they belittle
them and sometimes they
tortured them, right? And that
was the most extreme cases that
were happening in the later
days of the prophet
Dawah in Mecca, right? And then
it and then it turned into
full-blown war later on when he
moved to Medina. They still
wouldn't leave him alone. Now,
it was just pure violence and
and armies were attacking him
and his companions from every
single direction there is.
Right? Every tribe, they would
all collaborate and find a
common enemy and that was the
prophet tribes that had been
sworn enemies for centuries.
collaborated just to see the
downfall of the prophet and his
companions. So, bravery was not
just in the time of war,
bravery was also in the time of
peace. Bravery in our lives is
not just that we are willing to
put our body in harm's way.
That's that's not that
fantastic, really. It's not.
Non Muslims do that all the
time. Just fast What is
true fasting, right? Fasting
the prophet said,
Rafath. He said, true fasting
is not to just abstain from
food and drink and and and
deprive your body of food and
drink. True fasting is to
refrain from that which is
haram and that which is idle
and unusedful. That's what true
fasting is. There's fasting,
not eating all day until the
sun goes down, not drinking
anything. That's not that
fantastic. Most people can do
that on the first goal. Soccer
moms do that. Little girls
trying to lose weight, do that.
Everybody can do that, right?
It's not that fantastic. What's
fantastic is to control your
temper, control your heart,
control your right? That's that
that's that's where the rubber
meets the road. Control your
tongue Same thing with bravery.
Going out and fighting. Once
the fight starts or once the
battle begins, you're not
thinking about anything. You're
not scared anymore. Most people
once the battle begins and the
first bullets start flying or
the first sword starts
swinging. Call us. All you're
focused on is the fight. It's
not that fantastic. It's not
that amazing. Muslims and non
Muslims all do that. What's
is to be different amongst the
people that force you to be in
their way. That's amazing
What's brave is not to just
meet the enemy in the
battlefield. What's brave is
what the youth of the cave did.
Where they left everything and
they went and hid in this cave
because they refused to bow
down to other than Allah What's
what's brave is the prophet and
his companions leaving their
home and leaving their wealth
and moving to a strange land.
Right? This is bravery and when
a person does this, when a
person puts himself in that
kind of vulnerability, he is
actually opening his heart very
very much and this is what Ibn
il Kaim is referring to here.
So, it's not just I'm brave
because I can shoot a gun or
I'm not afraid of anybody and
all this tough guy talk. That's
everybody says that, right?
True, bra is your actions, that
you're willing to be different
for the right reasons in spite
of your environment. Everybody
is, is, is, is, is, going
against what is right, you have
the audacity to do what's right
in a in a in a wrong world. You
have the audacity to be good in
a bad world. You have the
audacity to say, this is wrong
and I will not engage in it. I
don't care who does, I don't, I
don't, it doesn't matter to me.
If the Sheikh himself says it's
okay all the way down to
whoever. I know this is wrong
and I will not engage in it and
I will not be pressured by any
society or anyone to engage in
it. That's bravery and that's
what the companions at the
beginning of Islam went
through. That's what was meant
by this religion began strange
and it will return to be
strange it began. because
just your breath, right?
First, your lungs are empty.
you take a deep breath, they
fill to capacity, but then the
breath comes out again, right?
We have an ark, and then we
have a climax, and then it
descends again. This is what
happened to the Muslim Ummah.
Right? Muslims within 23 years
of receiving all the way to
between these two verses, they
took over and they were able to
govern the majority, all of the
known world. And by the time of
the end of the, they were the
greatest empire that humanity
has ever seen and they were the
most effective empire. They
were the best thing that
happened to humanity. it's not
just about taking over land and
conquering land. The Romans did
that. The Persians did that,
right? The the the Pharaohs did
that. That's not what we're
talking about. We're talking
about they were able to not
only conquer but they were able
to conquer the hearts of
people. That's truly amazing
and they did that in how many
years? 40 years? Pretty fast.
And that legacy lasted for how
long? Last for about 1300
years. 1, 350 years until the
final collapse of the Ottoman
Empire and now everybody's off
doing their own thing.
Everybody's all willy nilly.
Our head got cut off. Whether
that was good or bad, this is
all part of the plan of Allah
This is one of the signs of the
hour, one of the signs of the
hour is one of the signs of the
hours One of the signs of the
hour that the prophet mentioned
is that there will be many many
police forces that will enforce
different laws and there will
be many many leaders. Each
person will take a piece of
land and have his own country
and they will be their own
king. This is this is exactly
what the prophet told us was
going to happen. Don't be
surprised by it. It's
dismaying. It's not nice. It
doesn't feel good. It doesn't
it's not nice to have non
Muslims tell us that there's a
difference between the
Jordanians and Palestinians and
Lebanese and Iraqi and and
Malaysian and and Indonesian
and this this is not pleasant,
right? And so you have
Palestinians that you know, you
know, when the English came and
they gave us our borders and
they said, okay, this is Jordan
and this is Palestine and this
is Syria and this is Lebanon
and this is Iraq and this is
Tunis and this is you know, and
they gave us all of these
things. We got these things
from non Muslims. Not how the
Muslim Empire was. Yeah, we we
used to describe certain areas.
This is the land of Iraq. This
is the, we didn't say it say
there's a difference between
us. Didn't say there's a
difference between Iraqi and a
Palestinian or a Yemeni but
when they gave us those borders
and they gave us patrols on
their borders, now, we start
to, oh, there's a big
difference. Palestinians are
good. Jordanians are bad.
Jordanians are good and
Palestinians are bad, etcetera,
etcetera. All this came from
home. All this came non
Muslims. This was the
inoculation that they gave us.
Right? This is this is only
exist in our heads. There's no
difference. There's no
difference. The only difference
between us is our is our
religion and our strength with
Allah. That's it. If you
want to be you know, we are we
are Egypt. We are the mother of
the Earth. We are the land of
knowledge. Okay, okay.
right? True valor and true
honor belongs to Allah and his
messenger and the believers.
That's it. Does it belong to
Egypt? It doesn't belong to
Palestine. It doesn't belong to
Jordan. It doesn't belong. This
is all just a bunch of false
things that a Shaitan put in
our heads to divide us. That's
what this is. There's no
difference. So, you're telling
me that that when I'm standing
on the border of Palestine and
I cross into the border of
Syria, there's somehow a
difference between the people.
There may be difference in the
way that we speak, difference
in the way that we cook our
food. What's the difference
between us and them? All of the
sudden, I have left the land of
of of of men of courage and
went into the land of the men
of of snakes and and and and
the feeble. This is nonsense.
This did not come to us from
the prophet or Allah. This came
to us from a Shaitan and his
minions from the human being
this is all very recent. This
was never something that
happened in the time of the
true the true leaders of Islam.
There was a and after that
there were states that would
follow that Khalifa. That's it.
Where are you from? I'm from
Iraq. I'm from Yemen. I'm from
Palestine. I'm from here. I'm
from there. All of that doesn't
mean anything. show us what
you're made of. Right?
and so what is, what is courage
courage is the strength of mind
and will To have fingers
pointed at you. We pointed out
and and looked at as as wrong
and weak and feeble and this
and that. Why? Because you are?
You are working with Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. What
people say is is immaterial to
you. It's not affect what you
know to be right. You read in
the Quran you read in the
Sunnah, this is wrong, you
follow it. And then other
Muslims will point fingers at
you. Because this religion
began strange and it will
return to be strange it
was before, right? So people
that wear your clothing and
speak your tongue, they're the
ones that will scold you for
it. They are the ones that will
say, what are you doing? And
this is not Islam, this is
this, this is that, right? When
you learn and you know this is
right, and you know this is
wrong, not suspect, not think,
not go on your own whim, not
make tough seal of the Quran on
your own. This is not what
we're speaking about. We're
speaking about no. This is an
issue of right and wrong. Not
an issue of difference of
opinion. That's that's a
totally different issue. We're
speaking about this is right
and this is wrong and you have
the audacity and the courage to
stand up and say no matter how
many people on this earth do
this, it will always be wrong
and I refuse to engage in this.
That's what is meant by
bravery. Right? You have the
courage to have less than
others because you're not
willing to do what others are
doing to get more. You have the
courage to live a different
lifestyle. style that is less
exciting.
Said, do not be fooled by all
of the travel and dazzle of the
people of disbelief in all of
the earth. This is just a
fleeting pleasure that they
will enjoy.
So, the the the the companions
they were fine, they were
upstanding, they believed in
the prophet all of a sudden,
they're in famine. All of the
sudden, nobody wants to do
business with them. All of the
sudden, their own mother and
father disowned them. All of
the sudden, right? And so, they
are suffering with the prophet
again, a book and a hope.
That's all they have to hold
onto. They may have lost thing.
Some of them lost their their
wives. Their wives left them. I
don't want to I don't want any
Muslim. I don't want anything
to do with that. Their own
mother and father left them.
Some of them were even chained
up in a room. in their own
home, by their own parents,
chained with chains. Right? In
their own in their own home.
And meanwhile, the non Muslims,
Abujah, Abulaha, all these
guys. the disbelievers, they're
traveling, they're eating
grapes from Damascus in in the
in the in the winter. They're
enjoying apples from over here.
They're traveling all over and
they have this fancy caravan
and everybody, you know, bows
down to them and so Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala tells the
companions and he tells the
prophet
[Silence]
Don't be fooled by this. This
is just busy work. You are the
ones that are on the truth.
Stay on the truth.
be afraid of man. What does
that mean to not be afraid of
man? Everybody has a natural
fear of being hacked to death
or shot or we all are afraid of
that, right? But are we all do
we find fear in our hearts from
our boss, from our from the
person who signs our paycheck
that maybe he won't sign it.
Maybe he'll fire me. Maybe if I
make salah or if I do the right
thing or if I don't do this
wrong thing, he's going to fire
me and that what am I going to
do? And then was your boss
there when the angel came to
your mother's womb and wrote
down what your bounty is
going to be in this world? He
wasn't there. Was he there when
you were born into this world?
Nope. You're going to be there
when you die in Passover? Nope.
It was only Allah that was
there. and so a bravery is
being able to look at the world
in this way. I will do what is
right regardless of the
consequences. Now, I think is
right. Not what my own opinion
tells me. We're speaking about
right and wrong. We're not
speaking about differences of
opinions and how to hold your
hands in salah and that stuff.
That's not what we're talking
about. We're talking about this
is right categorically. This is
hara categorically. I will not
bend the law of Allah. I will
ad here to it and let the chips
fall where they may. That's
bravery. And if you can exhibit
that, your heart is open and
the more you do that, the more
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala will
give you of his wisdom and of
his light. As enough for
tonight,
Muhammad Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala to grant us all true
bravery and that he Allah truly
opens our hearts to the Quran
and Sunnah and that he you
know, disturb the earth as much
as he needs to in order for us
to be, in order for, for us to
be in order for seeds and of
goodness to be sown in our
hearts that we meet him with.